Salut !
Il y a quelques jours, je vous ai fait la dernière vidéo de l'année concernant la mémoire,
aujourd'hui je vais vous faire la dernière vidéo de l'année concernant les mathématiques...
... ou du moins les astuces mathématiques qu'on a au fond de sa tête.
Juste le temps d'installer la caméra
en vous expliquant de quoi il va retourner.
Vous vous souvenez que je vous avais appris
dans l'année à extraire mentalement une racine carrée.
Il n'y a pas si longtemps que ça,
je vous ai appris à extraire mentalement une racine cubique,
et pour finir l'année en beauté je vais vous apprendre à extraire une racine cinquième...
mentalement.
Une racine cinquième c'est donc
je multiplie un nombre par ce nombre,
par ce nombre,
par ce nombre.
Ca donne un big résultat
et de ce big résultat
vous pouvez extraire quel était le nombre de départ qui a été multiplié cinq fois.
Ça sert surtout à se la péter.
C'est toujours une très bonne gymnastique en vrai.
Et si vous le faites,
je trouve ça cool de me dire que maintenant,
il y a des gens qui en regardant les vidéos,
savent faire mentalement
extraire une racine carrée,
une cubique,
et une cinquième.
Et je trouve que c'est le plus simple à faire
des trois extractions de racines mentales que je vous aurai données cette année.
Il y a une petite chose à savoir néanmoins.
De là j'arrondis tous ces résultats.
1 en résultat ça fera 1,
2 ça fera 30,
3 ça fera 250
4 ça fera 1000
5 ça fera 3000
6 ça fera 8000
EUH
7 ça fera 17000
8 ça fera 32000
et 9 ça fera 60000
et bien c'est cela que vous devez retenir c'est tous
Vous ne retenez que ça
C'est tout !!
C'est la seul chose et avec cela vous savez extraire tranquille une racine cinquième
Alors pour le faire d'une manière fun vous donnez votre calculatrice à quelqu'un
ou la personne met sa calculatrice sur son téléphone
Vous lui demander de penser à un nombre à deux chiffres dans sa tête
et de faire fois son chiffre,
fois son chiffre,
fois son chiffre, quatre fois d'affiler
imaginons que la personne prend 22, ça fait 22
fois 22 (X4)
égal
5 153 632
cette personne là doit vous donner ce résultat
elle doit soit vous le dire soit vous le montrer
et vraiment quasi instantanément vous savez quel a été son nombre de départ
la méthode est en 2 étapes pour retrouver le nombre de départ
On va dire le nombre initiale, on va l'apeller comme ça
pour retrouver l'unité du nombre initiale
vous regardez l'unité qu'il y a là, c'est la même
Si ça fini par 2 alors c'était 2
Si ça fini par 3 c'est que l'unité c'était 3
par 4 c'est que l'unité c'était 4
etc
ya pas a s’embrouiller
Donc il vous reste plus à retrouver maintenant le chiffre des dizaines
Et pour ça c'est extrêmement simple aussi
Vous supprimer les 5 premiers chiffres
Donc l'unité, les dizaines, les centaines, les milliers, les dizaines de milliers
Vous supprimez ça de votre champ de vision
Vous regardez que se qu'il y a après
Là dans l'exemple de 22 il n'y en a que 2 c'est 51
Et vous dans ce que vous avez mémoriser
Vous regardez ce qui est juste avant 51
Donc dans notre tableau on va dire mentalement on sait qu'il y a 1, 30, 250
Donc qui est ce qu'il a avant 51 c'est 30
Et 30 est associer au 2, Donc 2 et 2
22 on a bien notre 22
deuxième exemple
Voici le résultat(184 528 125), donc j'avais choisi un nombre a deux chiffres
Donc vous le multiplier par lui même et encore par lui-même et encore par lui-même et encore par lui-même
Donc ça ma donné ça, on sait déjà que m'on nombre initiale
finit par un 5
l'unité est un 5 car celui ci finit par un 5
Et si je supprime les 5 premiers chiffres
Donc l'unité, les dizaines, les centaines, les milliers, les dizaines de milliers
il me reste quoi ?
il me reste 1845
Et qu'est ce qui est juste avant 1845 dans mon tableau ??
Euh c'est 1000 et 1000 ça correspond à 4
Donc je sais que c'est 45
CQFD
Voilà vous savez le faire maintenant vous pouvez si vous voulez
Vous faire un petit papier
Avec le récap Euh l'espèce de tableau qu'il y a à connaître
Sinon vous trouvez un procédé mnémotechnique
Avec toutes les vidéos de truc de mémoire qu'on a fait cette année c'est pas compliqué non plus
et là il vous avez quand même un kit où il y a moyen de bluffer les gens
juste en faisant ok je vais essayer d'extraire une racine carré
puis après uns racine cubique
et puis je termine gentil par une racine cinquième
Si cette vidéo vous a plu n'oubliez pas de la liker
et de vous abonner et RDV demain à 17h
Tchao !
"musique"